und jetzt das heute journal
bettina zimmermann und christian sievers
[Musik]
guten abend in hallen der krieg gegen
die ukraine darf sich nicht ausbreiten
auf keinen fall dürfen auch wir direkt
mit hineingezogen werden und selbst
kriegspartei werden das ist das mantra
der bundesregierung die dringende
hoffnung der menschen hier und es ist
gleichzeitig eine ganz aktuelle gefahr
grund ist die russische exklave
kaliningrad das frühere königsberg nur
500 kilometer entfernt von berlin dort
eskaliert jetzt ein konflikt zwischen
russland und litauen es geht um eu
sanktionen und russische drohungen um
die brisanz zu verstehen beginnen wir
mit einem heute-journal überblick und
laura panik
[Musik]
ende des zweiten weltkriegs der
sowjetische staatschef stalin setzt im
potsdamer abkommen durch das königsberg
in die russische sowjetunion
eingegliedert wird und nicht in das
besetzte litauen so bleibt es auch nach
dem zerfall der sowjetunion eine
russische exklave also von fremdem
staatsgebiet umschlossen das territorium
russlands
seinen heutigen namen bekam kaliningrad
schon 1946 benannt nach dem im selben
jahr verstorbenen sowjetischen
staatsoberhaupt michail kalinin
kaliningrad liegt zwischen litauen und
polen bietet russland den strategisch
wichtigen zugang zur ostsee
bereits während des kalten krieges wurde
die hafenstadt heimat der sowjetischen
ostsee flotte und somit zu einer art
festung mitten in europa die nato blickt
mit sorge ins russische kaliningrad das
liegt auch an der sogenannten zytokine
sie beschreibt den landstrich zwischen
belarus und kaliningrad der litauen von
polen trend nur 65,4 kilometer luftlinie
und eine achillesferse der nato
litauen hat jetzt den güterverkehr
eingeschränkt der von russland nach
kaliningrad durch litauen läuft will
damit die eu-sanktionen umsetzen
russland droht offen mit schwerwiegenden
folgen es wären auch folgen für uns denn
litauen ist eu und nato partner
natalie steger mit mehr ein sehr
spezielles dreiländereck von polnischem
gebiet der blick drüben der kleine wald
gehört zu litauen hinter dem grünen
zusammen direkt das russische
kaliningrad
wir leben genau an der grenze und für
uns ist klar wir würden als erster
attackiert manchmal habe ich solche
gedanken
leben an der suzuki lücke zwischen
kaliningrad und belarus im falle eines
militärischen konflikts könnte russland
versuchen die baltischen staaten zu
isolieren
strategisch hochsensibel
hier haben wir den direkten kontakt zur
grenze der russischen föderation und
hier ist so viel platz dass
panzerkolonnen problemlos passieren
könnten
in kaliningrad hat moskau nach eigenen
angaben atomwaffenfähige iskander
raketen stationiert und ausgerechnet um
kaliningrad nun der streit
litauen lässt güter wie metalle stahl
und baumaterial nicht mehr über sein
staatsgebiet rein in die russische
exklave
die betroffenen waren wurden bislang aus
russland per zug wie erlitten dorthin
transportiert in kaliningrad decken sich
viele im baumarkt
vielleicht gehen die preise hoch oder
wir werden gar keine produkte mehr
bekommen an die wir gewöhnt sind
40 bis 50 prozent der waren würden bald
fehlen sagt der gouverneur von
kaliningrad und moskau droht
entsprechende maßnahmen werden auf
interministerieller ebene ausgearbeitet
und in naher zukunft ergriffen sie
werden ernsthafte negative folgen für
die litauische bevölkerung
ein militärischer angriff russlands auf
ein nato land gilt als wenig
wahrscheinlich andere maßnahmen schon
wir können davon ausgehen dass es heavy
metal diplomatie geben wird harte
rhetorik aus moskau säbelrasseln
drohgebärden möglicherweise auch
provokationen wie beispielsweise
luftraumverletzungen von putin heute
kein wort zu kaliningrad nur dass er die
streitkräfte verstärken werde angesichts
möglicher betrug litauen lässt sich
nicht einschüchtern in sachen transit
streit nach kaliningrad man setze
lediglich die eu sanktionen um litauen
hat kein interesse daran irgendetwas zu
eskalieren aber es gibt die sanktionen
und sie müssen umgesetzt werden ein
streit an einer strategisch heiklen
stelle auch für berlin von besonderer
bedeutung
deutschland führt in litauen die
nato-mission an hat sein engagement
zuletzt verstärkt so abschrecken in
diesen zeiten ist es mir wichtig dass
eines ganz klar wird
deutschland steht eng an der seite
litauens und aller unserer östlichen
allierten
russland will jetzt verstärkt waren über
den seeweg nach kaliningrad liefern der
transit streit ist ein weiterer konflikt
zwischen russland und der eu
während sich da also ein neues konflikt
szenario zusammenbraut ändert die
bundesregierung heute überraschend ihre
kommunikationsstrategie eine exakte
zusammenstellung der deutschen
waffenlieferungen an die ukraine gibt es
jetzt doch als liste im internet und der
spd chef lässt aufhorchen weil das was
er sagt nicht nur für seine partei eine
zeitenwende ist lars klingbeil sieht
deutschland in neuer rolle als zitat
führungsmacht mehr dazu jetzt von klaus
brodbeck aus berlin
so geht es wenn gewissheiten
gewohnheiten schlagartig wenig wert
scheinen weil die gegenwart dagegen ist
die spd und die zeitenwende
sie wird uns viel abverlangen sie
markiert eine zäsur die umbrüche ich
habe es gerade gesagt werden
auswirkungen auf unser zusammenleben auf
die politik auf die gesellschaft der
nächsten 10 15 20 jahre haben klingbeil
korrigiert den kurs seiner partei und
damit womöglich auch des landes weg von
der außenpolitischen bescheidenheit
vergangener jahrzehnte
deutschland muss den anspruch einer
führungsmacht haben nach knapp 80 jahren
der zurückhaltung hat deutschland heute
eine neue rolle im internationalen
koordinatensystem deutschland hat sich
in den letzten jahrzehnten ein hohes maß
an vertrauen erarbeitet
und dieses vertrauen geht mit einer
erwartungshaltung einher auch das
kanzleramt ändert heute sein und kurs
statt geheimhaltung nun transparenz
veröffentlicht ab sofort tagesaktuell
was deutschland der ukraine geliefert
hat und noch liefern wird munition
panzer auch die ersehnten
panzerhaubitzen 2000 design endlich
heute angekommen jubelt der ukrainische
verteidigungsminister auf twitter sie
brächten hitze ins gefecht
haben dann spargelfahrt der
konservativen seeheimer in der spd auf
dem berliner wannsee und ein kanzler der
sich seinen leuten erklärt was haben wir
entschieden aus guten gründen weil das
jetzt nicht mehr richtig gewesen wäre
aber es ist trotzdem eine weitreichende
mutige entscheidung bin sehr dankbar
dafür dass diese entscheidung auch so
breit getragen worden ist von der ganzen
fraktion und von der partei alle haben
das gleiche gedacht das ist jetzt
notwendig darum machen wir das und darum
wird das auch unterstützt von den
bürgern und bürgern dieses landes
zweifel daran dürfte man haben auch in
der spd gut zu sehen an diesem abend
ja da gibt es einiges noch einzuschätzen
mit controller banerjee in berlin guten
abend chuck und alaa fangen wir mal an
mit dem was lars klingbeil da gesagt hat
neue deutsche außen- und
sicherheitspolitik deutschland als
führungsmacht was der spd chef fordert
ist das auch eine ansage
seiner partei ja das ist das eindeutig
die spd ist ja keine radikal
pazifistische partei aber sie hat sich
in der vergangenheit schwer getan mit
der debatte über eine neue rolle
deutschlands in der außen und
sicherheitspolitik vor allem wenn es um
mehr militärischen einsatz geht so sehr
dass zuletzt hier in berlin auch
kritische stimmen laut wurden die
vermuteten dass die zögerlichkeit des
kanzlers bei der frage der unterstützung
für die ukraine vielleicht auch zu
großer rücksichtnahme für die spd
zurückzuführen sei und wer co
parteivorsitzende klingen bei läutet
jetzt eben mit seinen worten eindeutig
neue zeiten ein oder er versucht es
zumindest unter verweis auf die
zeitenwende die olaf scholz im bundestag
ausgerufen hat und auch mit viel lob für
den aktuellen kurs von bundeskanzler und
bundesregierung dass es ganz sicher für
die spd in teilen eine zumutung dass er
da unter anderem von militärischer
gewalt als mittel der friedenspolitik
auch spricht und es ist auch noch nicht
klar ob die partei ihrem vorsitzenden
und dem bundeskanzler auf diesem kurs
folgt aber die debatte ist jetzt
eröffnet und dann eine neue
kommunikationsstrategie im umgang mit
waffenlieferungen warum das jetzt
nachdem die bundesregierung genau das ja
immer abgelehnt hatte mit verweis auf
geheimhaltung
notwendigkeiten die bundesregierung
erklärt dass heute damit dass sie sich
damit der praxis der engsten verbündeten
zum beispiel der usa an passt aber da
muss man sagen davon hat sie ja vorher
auch keiner abgehalten so wirkt es dann
heute so als würde sie hier versuchen
aus der defensive zu kommen weg von der
kritik sie seien zu unklar und sie würde
zu langsam liefern und man wisse auch
gar nicht was da geliefert wird es passt
heute natürlich ganz gut dazu dass man
gleich auf der liste die panzerhaubitzen
als geliefert abhaken kann die er jetzt
in der ukraine angekommen sind und es
kommt auch rechtzeitig vor dem morgigen
auftritt des bundeskanzlers der morgen
eine regierungserklärung im bundestag
halten wird und der
verteidigungsministerin die sich im
bundestag den fragen der abgeordneten
stellen muss ich mag unter vielen dank
heute abend für diese analyse im
heute-journal und später im
heute-journal update fragen von gundula
gause dazu an roderich kiesewetter den
verteidigungsexperten der union
heute ist tag der industrie und es ist
gleichzeitig tag der sorgenvolle
gesichter der bundesverband der
deutschen industrie lädt ein eine
mächtige interessensvertretung und
lobbyorganisation ihr tag heute das
jährliche hochamt des bdi wie eine
zeitung schreibt und tatsächlich pilgert
die gesamte spitzenpolitik dorthin und
muss sich große sorgen anhören von einer
doppelten krise spricht der bdi chef
tatsächlich ist die situation geradezu
paradox es gibt immer noch volle
auftragsbücher und hohe auslastung der
kapazitäten und gleichzeitig düstere
aussichten ihre prognose für die
wirtschaft korrigiert deutschlands
industrie heute drastisch nach unten
elisabeth schmidt berichtet
eigentlich finden hier konzerte und
partys statt die spitzenvertreter der
deutschen industrie laden heute in
dieser event halle in berlin doch statt
feierlaune schmerzen an der
achillesferse der industrie die
energieversorgung hängt weiter am
russischen gas topf keine energie keine
industrielle produktion problem
ausgemacht wir haben uns die feuerwehr
gespart weil wir das brandrisiko für
vernachlässigbar gehalten haben und
jetzt brennt es lichterloh
deshalb waren die entlastungs paket im
großen und ganzen richtig aber sie sind
wir wissen keine dauerhafte lösung es
ist ein paradox die auftragsbücher der
unternehmen sind voll und doch spricht
die branche ganz offen von einer
drohenden rezession
die konjunkturprognose schraubte der
industrieverband herunter von 3,5
prozent zu jahresbeginn auf jetzt 1,5
prozent lieferketten stress
rohstoffmangel energiekrise die
industrie hofft auf mehr geld von der
bundesregierung von dort heute erstmal
eigenlob schon 2030 sollen 80 prozent
unseres strombedarfs und 50 prozent der
wärme aus erneuerbaren quellen gedeckt
sein
damit wird unser land schritt für
schritt unabhängig von fossilen
energieträgern und schwankenden
energiepreisen doch auch die
bundesregierung will was von der
industrie auf sie müsse den ausbau der
erneuerbaren beschleunigen
viel zu spät sagt die union wenn es nach
ihr geht sollen längst begraben
energieträger wieder auferstehen wir
sollten auch durchaus in erwägung ziehen
die drei noch verbliebenen
kernkraftwerke in deutschland länger
laufen zu lassen
meine damen und herren wir wissen
spätestens seit den letzten tagen dass
das sowohl technisch möglich als auch
juristisch vertretbar ist die drei
kernkraftwerke stellen derzeit nur rund
sechs prozent der deutschen
stromversorgung zum vergleich 15 prozent
des stroms kommen aus erdgas ersetzen
durch atomstrom schwer möglich und mit
dem beschlossenen aus der kernenergie
zum jahresende wird es auch keine
brennstäbe mehr geben doch die atomlobby
beschwichtigt wir könnten durch
bestimmte maßnahmen in der nutzung der
vorhandenen brennelemente ein paar
monate das noch strecken dann könnte es
unter umständen eine lücke geben bis
neue brennelemente zur verfügung stehen
aber für den winter 23 24 sollte es zu
schaffen sein dass die anlage mit neuen
brennelementen wieder mit voller
leistung am netz sind
klimafreundlicher als erdgas sei
atomstrom allemal doch der grüne
wirtschaftsminister setzt auf kohlestrom
politisch zähneknirschend wir müssen
getrieben durch die not des tages jetzt
wieder mehr fossile energien verbrennen
und in den markt bringen als wir
eigentlich wollten gleichwohl notwendig
weil es darum geht ich habe es eben ja
schon skizziert eine schwere ökonomische
krise abzuwenden von der gesellschaft
von deutschland wie viel der
bundesregierung ihre prinzipien wert
sind und woher die milliarden euro
kommen sollen um die wirtschafts krise
abzuwenden viele fragen täglich werden
es mehr
christian lindner ist der
bundesfinanzminister genannter lindner
einen schönen guten abend wenn die
auftragsbücher voll sind und die
aussichten für die deutsche industrie
dennoch besorgniserregend dann läuft
doch was gigantisch schief oder ja es
besteht die gefahr einer sehr ernst zu
nehmenden wirtschaftskrise aufgrund der
stark gestiegenen energiepreise aufgrund
der lieferketten probleme aufgrund auch
der inflation deshalb muss es jetzt die
erste priorität sein in der wirtschafts
und finanzpolitik alles zu unternehmen
um die inflation zu stoppen nicht nur
wegen der wirtschaft sondern weil viele
menschen ja auch sorgen haben ob sie das
leben bezahlen können hat uns der
russische präsident viel mehr in der
hand als wir wahrhaben wollen
ja die wirtschaftlichen auswirkungen
sind enorm aber nein putin hat uns nicht
in der hand sondern wir sind die
gestalterinnen und gestalter unseres
schicksals wir können unsere
energieversorgung
diversifizieren also andere quellen auf
der welt finden wir können andere
lieferketten schließen wir können frei
handeln mit anderen ländern betreiben um
dadurch neue wirtschaftliche
perspektiven zu haben und wir können
auch unsere eigenen möglichkeiten nutzen
bei der energieversorgung
etwa die heimischen gas und ölvorkommen
sind inzwischen viel wirtschaftlicher
als noch vor wenigen monaten aufgrund
der gestiegenen weltmarktpreise ich darf
jetzt keine denk tabus geben wenn es
darum geht die preisentwicklung für die
menschen zu kontrollieren okay das nehme
ich gleich mal auf denkt abos wir haben
so sagen zumindest manche forscher
möglicherweise zu erwarten eine
wirtschaftskrise wie seit 1945 nicht
mehr sie haben es gesagt die
energiepreise gehen durch die decke das
sind ja existenzielle fragen die
antworten allerdings die die
regierungskoalition darauf gibt die
gehen diametral auseinander ist es das
was deutschland jetzt braucht
wo gehen die antworten diametral zum
beispiel sagen sie wir können auch in
deutschland etwas tun wir können energie
fördern damit meinen sie fracking
nämlich an sie sagen in der fdp die
atomkraft ließe sich länger laufen spd
und grüne also ihre koalitionspartner
lehnen beides ab ist das ihr krisenplan
herr lindner darüber muss man zumindest
sprechen meine sorge ist dass wir in
einigen wochen und monaten eine sehr
besorgniserregende situation haben
könnten und in dieser situation dürfen
wir nicht wählerisch sein es geht ja um
3 bis vielleicht fünf jahre der
knappheit und dafür müssen wir eine
antwort finden eine antwort ist der
ausbau der erneuerbaren energien da sind
alle einer meinung eine antwort ist dass
wir flüssiggas importieren dafür
brauchen wir jetzt schwimmende terminals
schiffe die das in unser gasnetz
einspeisen können das habe ich als
finanzminister finanziert dann müssen
wir die planungen beschleunigen damit
das realisiert werden kann da sind wir
einer meinung richtig ist wir haben auch
noch andere möglichkeiten wir haben öl
und gasvorkommen in der nordsee und an
land und wir haben drei funktionsfähige
kernkraftwerke und ich finde schon dass
es notwendig ist darüber zu sprechen ob
diese möglichkeiten für einen
übergangszeitraum ob diese möglichkeiten
nicht ausgeschöpft werden die gaspreise
und die energiepreise steigen so stark
ab dass länder in welchen luxus in euro
men streiten sie sich doch eher darüber
und es gibt kein ergebnis
ja es ist richtig dass es gegenwärtig da
kein einvernehmen gibt aber es gibt
keinen streit nicht jeder
meinungsaustausch
ist er automatisch ein streit und ich
bin auch gar nicht entschieden zu
fordern wir wollen etwa bei der
kernenergie verlängern aber ich würde
gerne alle argumente und alternativen
kennen mich befriedigt jedenfalls nicht
dass wir die
klimaschädliche kohle verlängern die
möglichkeiten der kernenergie aber nicht
einmal in erwägung ziehen und genau das
würde ich gerne ändern mindestens in
erwägung ziehen muss man unideologisch
für die nähere zukunft angesichts dieser
enorm gestiegenen preise ich glaube die
menschen erwarten dass auch von der
politik schon die anreize helena auf gas
jetzt zu verzichten für die industrie
aber auch für die privaten
verbraucherinnen und verbraucher wird
viel geld kosten ihr geld
beziehungsweise eigentlich unser geld
das sie aber für uns ausgeben jetzt
wurde in extremen notsituationen die
schuldenbremse ausgesetzt wegen der
pandemie warum nicht jetzt auch in
dieser extremen notsituation im jahr
2022 ist die schuldenbremse ausgesetzt
wir haben gerade eine über 30 milliarden
euro paket an entlastungen beschlossen
das kommt überhaupt erst ja noch bei den
menschen an kindergeld energiepreis
pauschale eeg-umlage abgesenkt und so
weiter und so fort wir finanzieren auch
diese
lng terminals mit schulden das heißt ich
bin hier nicht orthodox wenn es
notwendig ist werden ausgaben finanziert
nur ist ja ist der staat auch selbst
opfer von inflation die zinsen die ich
von ihrem geld bezahlen muss die werden
im nächsten jahr auf 30 milliarden euro
ansteigen im letzten jahr waren es vier
nächstes jahr 30 milliarden das ist ein
ganz deutliches signal an die politik
wir können mit dem schuldenmachen nicht
so weitermachen wie bisher klarer gesagt
wir können uns immer mehr schulden gar
nicht mehr leisten weil auch der staat
inzwischen hohe zinsen zahlt gut helena
aber sie haben in diesem jahr neue
schulden von über 200 milliarden euro
und wenn sie die schuldenbremse im
nächsten jahr einhalten wollen dann
können sie maximal 7,5 milliarden euro
machen an neuen schulden das ist ja eine
haushaltspolitische vollbremsung die sie
da hinlegen wollen und das mitten in
dieser schwierigen existenziellen krise
nein nicht ganz also in diesem jahr sind
239 milliarden im nächsten jahr 100
milliarden
ja das wird in den nächsten jahren hier
anfallen in diesem jahr anfallen 139
bundeswehr vermögen bundeswehr
sonderprogramm später nächstes jahr um
die zehn milliarden euro aber
es waren ja einige sonderausgaben wegen
der kona pandemie weg ich will die auch
die aufgabe aber dennoch nicht
kleinreden es ist eine erhebliche
konsolidierungsanstrengungen die wir
aber unternehmen müssen das ist nicht
mein dachte mir macht es auch nicht spaß
den anderen ministerinnen und ministern
zu sagen dieses vorhaben geht nicht nur
eine maßnahme um inflation zu bekämpfen
ist dass der staat druck von den preisen
nimmt wenn der staat immer mehr
subventionen zahlt wenn der staat mit
steuergeld die preise antreibt bekommen
wir die inflation nie in den griff das
heißt die aufgabe ist raus aus den
schulden menschen gezielt entlasten
nicht alleine lassen mit der inflation
und dann druck von den preisen nehmen in
denen man dafür sorgt dass andere form
das wachstum zu fördern stärker werden
also bürokratieabbau auf zum beispiel
sagte bundesfinanzminister christian
vielen dank für das gespräch ich danke
ihnen und
das gespräch haben wir um 20 uhr
aufgezeichnet und die situation vor ort
in der ukraine jetzt mit johanna im
osten und süden des landes gingen auch
heute die kämpfe weiter in der region
raacke sollen durch russische raketen 15
menschen getötet worden sein das
berichtet der gouverneur des gebiets
schwere gefechte wurden auch aus der
stadt zaria otto netz gemeldet und im
gouverneur von lohans kam es im
industriegebiet der stadt zu massiven
artillerie und raketen beschluss
cdu und grüne in schleswig holstein
haben ihre koalitionsverhandlungen
erfolgreich abgeschlossen das erklärte
ministerpräsident günter morgenschweis
die beiden parteien zu den genauen
details des koalitionsvertrags äußern
zustimmen müssen anfang kommender woche
dann noch die beiden landesparteitage
dies gilt jedoch als sicher genauso wie
die wiederwahl günthers im landtag
fluggastdaten dürfen nach einem urteil
des europäischen gerichtshof von
eu-staaten weiter gespeichert
allerdings zukünftig nur begrenzt
verarbeitet werden nämlich auf das für
den kampf gegen den terror notwendiger
das gilt für alle flüge in die eu und
aus der eu heraus außerdem sollen die
mitgliedstaaten zukünftig daten und auch
sechs monate statt fünf jahre lang
speichern dürfen lediglich daten von
menschen die im zusammenhang mit
gefährlichen straftaten stehen dürfen
länger aufbewahrt werden
die documenta in kassel als vielleicht
wichtigste ausstellung für
internationale zeitgenössische kunst
weltweit lebt auch von der diskussion
vom anecken und vom streit immer schon
sie steht für überraschung und für das
unerwartete aber jetzt steht sie im
mittelpunkt einer kontroverse die weit
darüber hinausgeht ich bin wütend
enttäuscht und verletzt sagt kassels
oberbürgermeister
vor allem aber stellen sich viele fragen
auch und gerade an die organisatoren der
schau das umstrittene kunstwerk das
wegen massiver antisemitismus vorwürfe
in der kritik steht wird jetzt entfernt
die bilder des anstoßes ein schweins
gesicht mit der aufschrift mossad dem
israelischen geheimdienst
klischeehaft abwertende anspielungen auf
juden bilder die viele dokumente
besucher verstören
schon sehr grenzüberschreitend
falles generell eben das ganze volk der
jugend stigmatisiert wir sind hier in
deutschland das ist nun mal so und das
ist eine ausstellung die international
von diesem land ausgeht da kann man das
nicht zulassen finde ich erst am
wochenende war das vor 20 jahren
entstandene werk der indonesischen
künstlergruppe darin party aufgestellt
worden die künstler äußerten sich
gestern schriftlich zu den darstellungen
alle auf dem banner abgebildeten figuren
nehmen bezug auf eine im politischen
kontext indonesiens verbreitete symbolik
zum beispiel für die korrupte verwaltung
die militärischen generäle und ihre
soldaten die als schweinhund und ratte
symbolisiert werden um ein
ausbeuterische kapitalistisches system
und militärische gewalt zu kritisieren
eine erklärung die der zentralrat der
juden nicht akzeptiert immer dann wenn
der vorwurf des antisemitismus für
kunstwerke aber auch bücher egal bei
irgendetwas kommt sofort der
abwehrreflex so habe ich ist oder so
haben wir es nicht gemeint wenn man
diese eindeutig antisemitischen
darstellungen auf diesem bild zieht tut
mir sehr schwer dies nachzuvollziehen
die chefin der documenta heftig unter
druck entschuldigt sich heute auch für
das indonesische kuratorenteam gemeinsam
mit roo an grupa dem artistik team und
den künstlerinnen und künstlern haben
wir versichert dass auf der documenta
fifteen keine antisemitischen inhalte zu
sehen sein werden andernfalls würden wir
umgehend einschreiten dieses versprechen
haben wir leider nicht gehalten und das
hätte nicht passieren dürfen das will
ich aufgeklärt haben wie das passieren
kann und dann muss sichergestellt werden
muss überprüft werden damit wir klar
haben dass es nicht weitere bilder
weitere ausstellungs formate gibt in
denen antisemitische bildsprache gezeigt
wird nach den heftigen protesten wurde
das umstrittene banner gestern verhüllt
noch heute abend soll es nun ganz aus
dem stadtbild verschwinden die
diskussion um antisemitismus auf der
dokumente aber bleibt
und jetzt nochmal wirtschaft und nochmal
hanna und zwar mit einer herben schlappe
für den bayer-konzern der oberste
gerichtshof der usa hat heute einen
berufungsantrag des unternehmens
abgelehnt bei dem es um ein wichtiges
glyphosat urteil ging fragen wir nach
bei sina mainitz in frankfurt was
bedeutet die entscheidung des supreme
courts jetzt genau für bayer also das
die berufung vom obersten gerichtshof
der usa nun tatsächlich abgelehnt wurde
das ist zwar nicht überraschend aber
schon ein weiterer rückschlag für bayer
im skandal um das
unkrautvernichtungsmittel glyphosat
kläger werfen bayer vor glyphosat seien
krebserregend der konzern bestreitet das
aber die anhaltenden
rechtsstreitigkeiten kratzen am image
und auch investoren sehen die einzige
monsanto übernahme inzwischen als fehler
an im juni 2018 kauft bayer den
us-konzern der dass glyphosat produkt
roundup herstellt 60 milliarden us
dollar ließ sich bayer diese übernahme
kosten der kurs der bayer-aktie hat
seitdem 34 prozent eingebüßt doch damit
nicht genug der glyphosat skandal
brachte die leverkusener in vielerlei
hinsicht ein sehr unruhiges fahrwasser
inzwischen hat bayer etliche milliarden
für rechtsstreitigkeiten
zurückgestellt und künftig will man sich
direkt und außergerichtlich mit
potenziellen klägern einigen heißt es ab
dem kommenden jahr soll dann nicht mehr
ein hobby gärtner sondern nur noch in
der landwirtschaft verkauft werden vier
jahre glyphosat streit täuschen
inzwischen manches mal über die sonst
recht gute bilanz des pharma- und
chemieriesen aus leverkusen hinweg und
das wird wohl auch noch eine weile so
bleiben viel ärger den sich bayer
vielleicht hätte ersparen können
gesehen hat für diese anordnungen
knapp fünf monate nach den tödlichen
schüssen auf zwei polizisten in der nähe
von kusel hat der prozess gegen den
mutmaßlichen schützen begonnen das
gericht wirft dem 39 jährigen zweifachen
mord vor dieser erklärte heute er sei
nicht der alleinige schütze gewesen sein
mutmaßlicher komplize habe die
polizistin erschossen und habe aus
notwehr gehandelt bei einer nächtlichen
verkehrskontrolle ende januar waren eine
polizeianwärterin und ihr kollege
getötet worden mutmaßlich um
jagdwilderei zu vertuschen
und es gibt eine unwetterwarnung des
deutschen wetterdienstes vor schwerem
gewitter mit orkanböen heftigem
starkregen und hagel im süden bayerns
und baden württembergs
zur schwimm-wm in budapest und dem
dritten medaillen jubel für deutschland
florian wellbrock hat über 800 meter
freistil die silbermedaille gewonnen und
das in deutscher rekordzeit
schneller war nur der us-amerikaner
briefing bronze sicherte sich wellbrock
ukrainischer trainingspartner michael
jung romantschuk
was für eine geschichte nach uns in der
immer sehenswerten 37° -reportage drei
schülerinnen und schüler aus der
abschlussklasse einer kölner hauptschule
es geht um den kampf gegen vorurteile
und den sprung in einen neuen
lebensabschnitt
seien sie dabei und genießen sie jetzt
den rest des tages länger werden sie
nicht mehr dieses jahr und wir wünschen
ihnen noch einen schönen abend
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zum wetter heute
abend zum sommeranfang dem längsten tag
des jahres und den neben meteorologen
weltweit zum anlass sich noch einmal die
sogenannten wärme streifen anzuschauen
er tat es wollte damit 2018 auf einfache
weise die erd- erhitzung zeigen jeder
streifen zeigt ob das jeweilige jahr
global wärmer oder kälter war als im
durchschnitt das ganze läuft von 1850
bis
2021 und es wird eben deutlich wie viel
fahrt die erhitzung seit 1980
aufgenommen hat jetzt kommen wir zu
unserem wetter da bringt eine kaltfront
in den süden des landes deutliche
feuchte und labile luft und in genau
dieser luft gibt es eben heute abend und
in der nacht im südwesten auch einige
teils kräftige schauer und gewitter
richtung norden ist es oft klar hier
sinken die temperaturen auf 7 bis 12
grad in der gewitter luft da ist es ein
bisschen milder mit 13 bis 18 grad
morgen haben wir an den küsten um die 20
grad sonst ist es verbreitet sommerlich
bei 25 bis 30 grad dazu scheint in der
nordhälfte auch richtig viel die sonne
nur in schleswig holstein ist es unter
dem hochnebel etwas bedeckter im süden
aber im saarland sieht rheinland pfalz
bayern und baden württemberg sind immer
wieder schauer und gewitter unterwegs
zum einen noch morgens aus der nacht zum
anderen dann nachmittags wieder
kräftiger und da können eben örtlich
auch unwetter mit starkregen hagel und
sturmböen dabei sein ab donnerstag
bleibt es weiter sommerlich heiß am
freitag sieht im moment alles nach einer
gewitter lage im westen des landes aus
auf wiedersehen